[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in a televised address
the country last night as you know the
president made his case for why America
needs a wall on our southern border and
why that wall is so important that is
worth shutting down the federal
government to get it
Democrats remained unmoved by the dress
leaders in Congress on the Democratic
side Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
delivered their party's initial response
their words were then echoed with
mechanical precision by Democrats up and
down the chain from sitting members of
Congress all the way down to the
left-wing lady muttering in your local
dog park talking points doesn't really
do justice to the rhetorical discipline
here it was really like watching a 3d
printer at work churning out carbon
copies of stilted propaganda one after
the other after the other a miracle of
replication you might even call the
Democratic response manufactured Paul
stated that this is a manufactured
crisis and a crisis that manufactured by
the Trump administration this is a
manufactured crisis bill how he
manufactures crises like immigrants
seeking legal refuge what the president
is doing is manufacturing a crisis
President Trump must stop holding the
American people hostage but to stop
manufacturing a crisis this president
just used the backdrop of the Oval
Office to manufacture a crisis so
they've brought back manufacturing what
about the press well one thing to know
about our national media if Democratic
leaders are saying it reporters are
saying it too no matter what it is you
often hear conservatives complain that
our media our liberal let's giving them
far too much credit what they really are
is obedient like shih-tzus begging for a
snack if Nancy Pelosi called for
invading Canada tomorrow all the news
anchors would be telling you how Ottawa
is the real threat their flunkies
humorless little functionaries doing
their sad little jobs watch them at work
folks the president has manufactured one
heck of a political crisis for himself
Donald Trump is manufacturing a national
security crisis you will hear you're
gonna say is that this is a manufacture
crisis it's not a national security
crisis from Nancy Pelosi down to Debbie
wasserman-schultz or anybody else who
will give him a dime for this project
manufactured it's a manufactured crisis
for the president to get a political win
we have a president who will go on TV
tonight and lie and lie and lie some
more there's a manufactured crisis
they're so dumb they have no
self-respect okay so we showed you the
mindless lies are telling you what are
Democrats actually proposing as an
alternative to the border wall we can
answer that question with some authority
because last week on January 3rd House
Democrats passed their own proposal they
say would secure our southern border
what's in it what would it do well
nothing that is not being done already
the democratic bill provides the same
funding for partial fencing border
security technology hiring more customs
officers and so forth that we already
have in other words the Democratic
border security plan is the status quo
Democrats argument is that things work
just fine right now instead of spending
another dollar to secure our border
Democrats in Congress have for example
just proposed spending another twelve
million dollars to investigate
reparations for slavery just to give you
some proportion in the sense of their
priorities so Democrats everything is
more important than border security and
that would be fine if our current
security was working it's not in fact
it's likely that more than 20 million
people already live illegally in our
country right now that's more than two
and a half times the entire population
of New York City and the actual number
may be bigger than that we don't really
know and that's the point it's totally
out of control the problem isn't the
border patrol doesn't have the right
technology to do the job the problem is
that politicians don't care to fix it
and if they did they could solve the
problem in an afternoon borders are not
that complex it's not like we're trying
to cure pancreatic cancer here our best
minds are stumped hardly what works for
hadrian will work for us it works for
Israel right now and a lot of other
places walls work that's when people
still build them everybody knows that
this is all a charade and we should at
least admit what's happening what you
saw last night was not too
party's bickering over the best way to
solve a shared problem no in this case
one sides problem is the other side's
solution for Democrats a porous border
is a good thing
unalloyed good thing it means more
low-wage workers for their donors that's
deeply appreciated it means more
compliant voters for them to replace the
millions of actual Americans they have
alienated and then there's the emotional
payoff of the whole thing
Democrats feel good about letting in
poor people from around the world these
are people who don't make a lot of
complicated demands about health care or
dental or unfunded pensions what their
kids should be doing for a living
they're not whiny like Americans they're
not living reminders of how politicians
have failed to fulfill their promises no
they're just grateful to be here they're
immigrants Democrats love people like
that in fact they've come to love them
much more than they love you
congresswoman Acacio Cortes said that
out loud just last night the women and
children on that border that are trying
to seek refuge and seek opportunity in
the United States of America with
nothing but the shirt on their backs are
acting more American than any person who
seeks to keep them out ever will be
so people who show up here and ignore
our laws are more American than you are
that's how Democrats feel keep that in
mind as you watch this debate